turning to politics newly released text
messages between former white house
chief of staff mark meadows and
republican lawmakers are revealing more
about efforts to overturn the 2020
election
one text message discussed the idea that
then president trump should declare
martial law to remain in office robert
costa in washington obtained the latest
text robert good morning good morning
these texts are a snapshot of the behind
the scenes frenzy inside the west wing
and inside the republican party before
and after the capital attack they also
preview some of the evidence the house
select committee might detail in its
upcoming public hearings and come as the
justice department continues to weigh
possible criminal contempt charges
against mark meadows
as rioters stormed the capitol on
january 6 white house chief of staff
mark meadows received a flurry of text
messages from republicans including the
president's son
urging him to intervene
donald trump jr warned he's got to
condemn this expletive asap and from
georgia congresswoman marjorie
taylor-green one of trump's staunchest
supporters this newly revealed plea
please tell the president to calm people
this isn't the way to solve anything but
just a day later greene wrote to meadows
spreading a false conspiracy theory that
antifa was mixed in the crowd and
instigated it and sadly people followed
the newly unveiled texts first reported
by cnn and confirmed by cbs news
are among more than 2
300 meadows provided to the house
committee investigating the capital
attack in a stunning message it was
revealed republican lawmakers even
discussed martial law using the military
to keep trump in power joseph robinette
just days before president biden's
inauguration on january 17th green
texted meadows
in our private chat with only members
several are saying the only way to save
our republic is for trump to call for
martial law
i don't know on those things i just
wanted you to tell him
that text raises new questions about her
testimony last week under oath during a
court challenge to keep her off the
ballot ms green did you advocate to
president trump to impose martial law as
a way to remain in power
i don't recall
so you're not denying you did it you
just don't remember i don't remember
and sources close to the select
committee say they plan to speak to
donald trump jr in the coming days trump
jr's knowledge of key political players
involved with that trump rally on
january 6 is of interest to the
committee our sources tell us as well as
his recollections from inside the oval
office and the west wing that day gail
all right robert thank you very much